let's bring in Mark Cuban the Mavs owner
he joins us now Dan Patrick show all
right what do you think about this
changing the dimensions of the floor in
the NBA no no simply because you have 30
arenas that were designed for that floor
and it would be physically impossible to
standardize it just can't work I have a
lot of free time mark I was just
thinking that when I I'm watching the
spacing there and everything's on the
perimeter and I just wondered if you
could you could extend it a little bit
or widen what would you want to change
in the NBA if you could right now oh my
goodness what what I want to change the
officiating seriously I mean that's my
20 year battle but you know the game is
beautiful right now it really really is
players understand that they have to add
skills rather than just bang or run or
even just catch a shoot and I think
that's really changing the game
significantly guys can put the ball on
the floor at any size they they can you
know pass the ball they're just all the
dynamics continue to evolve and that's
great for the game I would love to have
you ever thought about trying to referee
any of like a preseason game like at
Summer League and yeah that means I
don't want it that that would be a joke
yeah I mean I you know when I was in
school I rep read intramural and stuff
like that so it's not like I have zero
officiating experience but at the same
time I must and it's not a hard job it
is our job but management matters and so
you know we've got new people in place
we'll see what happens I was wondering
about you with what's going on with
Jerry Jones like at what point does an
owner become a detriment to the league
and and I'm sure ten years ago you had
owners who probably wanted you out you
know probably including the commissioner
oh yeah there was there was more than
one that wanted me out probably from the
time I walked into the door up until you
know 2008-2009 when they got used to me
but it's interesting when I noticed with
the commentary from the NFL when they
start using language like detrimental to
the
that's not an accident that's for legal
reasons because if the NFL is anything
like the MBA there's language that says
once you start taking actions that are
detrimental to the league if the league
takes actions against you then you're
responsible for paying all the Lynx
bills for it and so it was I'm sure it
was said with intent in mind you agree
with how Jerry's approached this well
there's two pieces to it right so first
is the astrick piece I don't know the
details behind what Zeek Elia did or did
not do you know domestic violence
violence against women women is an
important issue and I don't want to
diminish it at all and so you know it if
it's minimal like Jerry seems to think
then you know that's one situation if
it's not and it's very very serious like
the Commission seems to think that's
that's another thing but Kevin Jerry the
benefit of the doubt didn't seek the
benefit of the doubt that yes
Jerry's doing what he thinks is right
you know in professional sports
particularly football you only have a
moment in time where everything is
planed to your benefit where you have a
franchise quarterback and a franchise
running back and a franchise receiver in
a franchise tight end and you know once
one injury and that and get in an
instant and so Jerry is doing the right
thing for his team and its fans by
trying to get Zeke on the field and
doing whatever it takes but is he doing
the right thing for the league and the
other 31 owners by suing the league
obviously if I'm one of the other 31 I'm
saying no but I think you know Jerry
doesn't care about that just like I
didn't care about that you know he
represents the Cowboys he represents
Cowboys fans everywhere and that's
that's perspective he needs to take will
it have long-term detrimental impact on
the league you know
only only if what comes down about Zeke
10 ends up being bad if it ends up that
it's not bad and the leak overplayed his
hand then you know he's doing the right
thing 10 you said that the league was 10
years away from imploding you're talking
about the NFL that was 3 years ago has
timetables sped up or slowed down in
your opinion I just really slowed down a
little bit but I don't think the concept
has changed at all I think you know like
I said then climbing the mountain to get
to the top of your industry is hard
staying there is even harder and so on
and so I think that's still in place and
I think they overplayed their hand again
from creating too many TV shows too many
nights of football on TV I think that
was part of problem one maybe they're
recognizing maybe they're not the issue
with CTE I think is a far bigger issue I
think right now because they haven't
been able to solve it and I don't know
that it is solvable I think it's
starting to permeate throughout football
throughout the United States you know it
at every level I was talking to someone
from the NCAA and they said that
participation in high school football is
down dramatically everywhere except in
an SCC country their participation is
flat but if participation continues to
fall 10 percent a year you're not going
to have the face of fans that get
excited about it on Friday nights which
leads potentially to them being a lot
less excited about them on Sunday
afternoon and Sunday evening and so you
know I don't know necessarily that the
ratings are as reflective of a problem
as some people think but I think that
the decline in participation is a huge
problem I know I would I have an
eight-year-old son
he plays flag football and I love him
playing flag football but I wouldn't let
him play tackle football and but that's
not even that the bigger issue
the bigger issue is he'd rather watch
youtube videos than watch football with
me on Sunday afternoon literally we
watched the Steelers Chiefs game this
past weekend because I basically forced
him to it was the first time I've been
able to get him to watch game without
him having a device in his hand ever I
think that's part of the challenge for
the NFL
he's Mavs owner Mark Cuban joining a
Stan Patrick show what would stop you
from signing Colin Kaepernick as an NFL
cannot he could play that's they're not
even play yeah but even in this market
yeah it depends on the market you're in
I mean the what's changed is in the past
there would have been 10 15 20 beat
writers that would have had to written
something every single day
that's not really the issue any longer
whether it's bloggers or newspaper
review writers or even local media now
the issue is is social media and how
each team is prepared to deal with that
and to a lesser extent national media
but yeah if he could play winning cures
all you know it's you know what he did
it's making up for himself I don't think
it's going to prevent would not prevent
me from signing up though what's the
last time you were out in public and
just a regular citizen came up with a
great idea for Shark Tank well that's a
great question um you know I don't know
great idea but there's been times when
people look pitch the elevator pitch to
me you know 30 seconds or less and
giving them my email you know cuz that's
the hard part here's a tip for everybody
the longer that they want story the
worse the deal you're gonna pitch me or
anybody don't start with when I was a
kid my dad or my mom and yada yada yada
or you know I went through this this
problem and I solved it with that I
don't care right get to the meet you
know if you've got a good idea tell me
why tell me how why it's great and do it
in 30 seconds and if you can't do it in
30 seconds it's not a good an eye test
you think of it did you have a smile on
your face when LeBron was saying that
Dennis Smith jr. his you know his
man-crush that he should have been on
the Knicks that they made a mistake
passing him up know the exact tops I'm
like dude she just changed I can't
believe he fell into your lap I I just I
can't I mean he's an exciting kid all
right you know he is exciting and he's a
good kid too you know people don't
realize how much Dennis the junior and
Dirk have in common they have one
specific trait that that makes them
almost like twin they're both like when
Dirk was 20 he was a 40 year old in the
20 20 year old body Dennis Smith is a 50
year old in a 19 year old body the dude
is old
fortunately he doesn't have old lace and
he doesn't have just good basketball i.q
but it's crazy to talk to him well you
have a you're a 12 year old trapped in a
50 year old body aren't you
that is the damn truth great to catch up
thank you Mark
safe travels I appreciate that any for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]